- To be loved for one generation,
remembered for two generations,
and forgotten after that.
The best thing that ever happened to me is
I hit rock bottom.
By far the best thing
that ever happened to me
is hitting rock bottom.
Why can't you be
somebody that can do
something in your business
that's never been done before?
Why not you?
Answer it.
- He's an american entrepreneur
and financial advisor.
He speaks on a range of
topics including leadership
and how to become an entrepreneur.
He's published two books,
The 25 Laws of Doing the Impossible
and The Next Perfect Storm.
He's Patrick Bet-David,
and here is my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end for
a special bonus message.
And, as always, if Patrick says something
that really, really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(whooshing)
(uptempo music)
- Man, what happened to Pops
when he started a business?
He failed.
What happened to Mom and Dad?
They got a divorce.
What happened to us?
We lived six different places.
Was it fun?
Hell no, it wasn't fun.
What happened in high school to you?
Did you play baseball?
Did you play high school basketball?
Did you get picked up for football?
Did you date the girl you liked?
What was your GPA?
Who were you in high school?
Who were you afterwards?
What makes you think you're
going to make it in life?
You got to stop selling
this stuff to this guy, man.
Stop it, it's getting old.
Go get that job that you let go of,
paying you 12 bucks an hour,
and part-time get a degree.
Stop taking these damn risks.
We're not meant to do
something big with our lives,
simple as that.
- Are we done?
- I'm done, I'm good.
- Okay, good.
Pat, I want you to know, this voice
is never going away.
This voice is always going to be there.
No matter how much money
you're going to make,
it's always going to be there.
The great thing about it is, though,
every morning you wake
up, you have a choice
on which voice to listen to.
But I want you to think about
a completely different thing right now.
Let's just say you do nothing.
Let's just say you buy into your fears.
Let's just say you buy into
every single thing you're worried about.
Let's just say you
don't make any decisions
to go after your dreams.
Fast forward 10 years from now,
20 years from now, 30 years
from now, 40 years from now.
Let's just say your
funeral's around the corner.
You have 50 people
there, 100 people there,
maybe 200 people show up.
These are your friends, family,
and people that love you.
So you'll be loved for one generation,
remembered for two generations,
and forgotten after that.
Is that truly the life you want to live?
Is that really what you want to do?
I don't know if that's the
life you really want to live.
You see, what I've noticed is,
no matter what you ever do,
you'll have a lot of lonely times.
You can lie to your family,
you can lie to your friends,
you can fool the world into realizing that
why you didn't win was because of
some challenge that you had to face.
But there's one person
you can never lie to,
and that is the man in the mirror.
You can never lie to the
man in the mirror, never.
For the rest of your life,
the man in the mirror
is going to look back at you and say,
"You did not choose to
go after your dreams."
And you have to be okay with that.
Now, what I would like
to encourage you to do is
to make the right choice.
I encourage you to face your fears
and pursue your dreams.
Go pursue the dreams that
matter the most to you.
You only got one shot at this thing here,
and if it works out, man,
it's going to feel so good for you.
And if it doesn't, at
least you had the courage
to make that decision.
I hope you make the right choice.
I trust you will.
Let me tell you one thing that, you know,
most millionaires master
is reading people.
Reading people, and I'll tell you
what I mean by reading people, okay?
The reason why reading people,
millionaires end up generally
become good at reading people
is because they've been ripped off,
back-stabbed, lied to,
cheated so many times
that there are a lot of signals
that they see a trend of
saying this person's like that,
reminds me of this person.
You got to learn how to read people,
you got to learn how to read a customer,
you got to learn how to read an employee,
you got to learn how to read
someone who is absolutely full of it.
Sometimes I get surprised
how some people who are pretty successful,
they're making $100,
$200, $300,000 a year,
how easily they fall for the trap of
somebody who's full of it.
Like, how do you not read
that sometimes, right?
You got to learn how to read it,
and a certain level of paranoia
when you're reading people.
And then also, when I'm
saying reading people,
it's not just on a negative side.
Reading people on someone that's truly,
you did something wrong
and you need to go out there
and do something about it.
You need to read people that need
you to make a right effort
to take care of them.
You don't make the right effort to
treat them in a way that
they need to be treated.
That's also reading people.
Another one is when I
say reading people is
being able to think what a
customer is going to need now,
and what a customer is going
to need a year from now,
three years from now, five years from now,
and reading them.
Being able to read a person
that starts with your
company at an early stage,
and what were they thinking about
when they were at your level.
At a new level, you're
not speaking to them
from your level.
Millionaires, they got
to learn how to read
somebody at that level
and give them the belief
that they need at that level,
versus somebody that's
been around a little longer
that needs to kind of man up, or woman up,
or mature as an entrepreneur,
and they're not,
they're just treating this as a
lolligagging with the industry,
and that's a completely
different conversation
with that person.
Say, "Grow up already.
"You've been in this thing
for five, 10, 15 years,
"what's next?
"You're going to be like
this your entire life?"
So, reading to know when,
where, who, what, when.
They eventually become very
good at reading people.
I like shining shoes.
I like ironing clothes.
I like doing those types of things.
And I remember one time,
one of my mentors said,
"Do you want to make $10 an hour?"
I said no.
"Then why do you keep
doing $10 an hour jobs?"
I said, "What do you mean?"
He says, "You keep shining shoes,
"you keep doing this, you keep
liking those types of things,
"you got to get somebody
else to help you out."
So what happened?
I went 100% dry cleaners, even
when I couldn't afford it.
I was broke.
I went 100% dry cleaners.
I went 100% somebody else
helping my shine my shoes,
and I gave money to a business.
I got an assistant to
do my paperwork for me,
to do the filing for me,
to do all of those things for me,
to drop my car off at Jiffy
Lube to get an oil change,
to get a car wash.
Literally all of those activities
were done by somebody else,
and it became a match-up system to me.
I had somebody do those things for me,
were allowing me to do the other things,
even housecleaning, it
was somebody else doing it
where it's not me doing it.
Now, why is that important to do?
You got to get an assistant
so you can leverage your time.
Do not let $10 an hour job
get you out of business,
where you end up going back
and getting a job that
pays you only $10 an hour.
Focus on what grows your business.
I got a call from one of my friends
from many, many, many years ago,
growing up and he said, you know,
he's been trying to get
into a relationship,
and he says, "Pat," he's an entrepreneur,
he says, "Pat, I'm dating this girl,
"and I'm at a point right now
"where I feel like I need to settle down.
"I'm in my mid-30s."
I said, "Okay."
He says, "But she told me this."
I said, "What'd she tell you?"
She says, "It's either me or the business,
"because she can't stand the fact
"that I'm working the way that I am
"and I'm running a business."
And I said, "What's your answer?"
He says, "Well, I don't know.
"What do you think I should do?"
I said, "Well, I'm not going
to give you my advice."
I said, "What's, how
are you wired yourself?"
He says, "Pat, I don't
think I can really do this."
I said, "Why do you think?"
He says, "Because you're
asking me to change myself."
You see, when somebody says,
"It's either me or the business,"
let me explain to you how
an entrepreneur sees that,
so maybe it'll help understand.
The entrepreneur says,
"It's either your arm or me,
"what's more important?"
I love you, but I'm not
going to cut my arm off.
You're telling me to be a
whole different human being
to be with you.
We're not living in Biblical times.
I'm not going to cut my arm off for you.
If you want me, this is me.
This is how I come.
Do you like it?
You don't like it, go find somebody else.
But this is how I'm wired.
I've been like this for 22 years.
I've been like this for 38 years.
It doesn't mean I'm not going to change
and improve myself with maturity.
I am, but I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm in the hunt, I'm going after it.
I'm going to build something
special and significant for my life,
and I want to build it with you,
but not if you're trying to change me.
So, on the other side, somebody may say,
"Well, they spend more
time with the business.
"They love the business
more than they love me."
No, it's how they are.
It's how they are, it's how they're wired.
If somebody says,
"Babe, I'm pregnant,
"what do you want me to do?"
When you're pregnant, you go through this.
A man may feel like, "But
what's more important to you,
"the baby or me?"
What are you talking about?
This is something that we don't understand
when a first pregnancy.
We're on our third one now,
so now I get an understanding of it.
It's like, "Who's more
important, me or the baby?
"I'm your husband."
That's an ultimatum.
You don't put a mother
in a position like that.
You don't put an entrepreneur
in a position to say
it's the business or me.
They'll typically take them
as who they are for a human being.
'Cause the last thing you
want is to date somebody,
and then 10, 20 years
later they have resentment.
Then it can lead to worse things.
You had somebody that decided
to change their own DNA
to be with you, all because of you.
You have a delayed time bomb
of someone that could eventually become
your biggest enemy in your life,
because you tried to change them.
I don't recommend that.
One of the best recommendations I got
before I got married,
I was dating a girl at one point,
and I went to one of my
mentors, one of my pastors,
and I said, "Hey, this
is what I'm experiencing,
"what do you think?"
He said, "Does it bother you?"
I said, "A lot."
He said, "Can you deal without it?"
I said, "No, I cannot,
I can't deal with this."
And he said, "It's just going to get more,
"so if you can't deal with it now,
"don't think it's going to disappear."
And I have to make that
decision and move on.
It wasn't easy, it was
very difficult because,
you know, I really cared
for this human being,
but I have to move on.
So, if somebody's really
trying to change somebody,
and you're an entrepreneur,
if the person does change,
it's just a matter of time
'til the person goes back to
being true to who they are.
You're going to be true
back to who you are.
The entrepreneur, the real entrepreneur,
is going to go back
being true to themselves.
I was a young kid, just a knucklehead
who thought he knew everything.
You know, 21 years old, I
would've been so annoyed
coaching myself at that time,
'cause I thought I knew everything.
And then the best thing
that ever happened to me,
the best thing that ever happened to me is
I hit rock bottom.
By far the best thing
that ever happened to me
is hitting rock bottom.
I think, for men, I have two boys,
and I'm going to be in pain when I witness
these guys go through this,
but I think the best thing
that can happen to a man
is a heartbreak, a very strong heartbreak,
and a very big failure
early on in business.
And it happened to me early on in life,
both heartbreak and business.
It happened early on because
I thought I knew it all,
and it was a slap in the face to say,
if Socrates says, "The only thing I know
"is that I know nothing."
If the greatest minds, on their deathbed,
are saying things like that,
what makes you and I
think we know everything?
Quite frankly, everything
I'm saying on Valuetainment
may be inaccurate.
Every single thing I'm
saying on Valuetainment,
you may come back and my
opinions may be wrong.
It's worked for me.
This is how it's worked for me.
For me, it's more about
teaching how to think
than actually what to think.
I want to get an entrepreneur to learn
how to think than what to think.
But we don't know everything.
We got to learn how to adjust,
we got to learn how to adapt,
we got to learn how to get better,
we got to learn how to improve,
and so the mindset of
thinking you know it all,
it's just not a place you want to be,
'cause it means advancement
doesn't come around the corner,
and I had the know-it-all
attitude at a young age,
and it almost cost me.
There's a benefit to that.
There's a benefit because you become edgy,
you push the envelope a little bit,
but there's also the leveling off to know
that maybe you don't really know this,
so let me ask and question
somebody I respect
to give me proper direction that I trust
that maybe they can challenge
my position and opinion,
but it's good that I have the audacity,
so I like it, the fact
that there's audacity,
that you're pushing the envelope,
but there's got to be coachability
and learnability that you want
to learn and advance as well.
It doesn't matter who you are,
everyone's got to have somebody
that they have a mentor
that's giving them direction with.
So it was good that I got
out of that pretty quickly.
Energy and stamina.
It requires energy and
stamina to retain information.
So, if your body is
gaining too much weight,
and you're tired,
your body doesn't have
the energy and the stamina
to retain that information.
To retain information requires your body
to have the energy to retain it.
If it doesn't have it, it's
not going to retain it.
Come on, Pat, you're telling me my weight
has to do with retaining information?
Yes it does, yes it does.
'Cause retaining information
requires an effort,
and any time you need to take
an effort to do anything,
it's going to deplete what?
Energy.
And if you don't have
the energy in your mind,
it just says I don't have any interest
to want to retain this
information 'cause I'm tired,
and I don't have stamina,
and my energy's low.
That's why energy's a
very, very important gain,
and it's not just about money.
Energy is not just about looks,
and looking pretty, and exercising
'cause I want to look good.
Exercise when we're younger was for
a whole different purpose.
When you're married with kids
and later on you're an adult,
you're exercising for a
whole different reason.
Focus, energy, and stamina.
Sharper mind.
Selling is something you'll always do
the rest of your life.
Most people don't like selling.
Some people like to kind of make it nicer,
and some will use a better word
and say communication or this.
It's sales.
By the way, those that
just turned off the video
and don't want to watch
about what selling has to do,
hey, you want to marry that girl you love?
You know which one I'm talking about?
You need to sell her, and her parents,
and her best friends.
That's all selling.
You want to get that promotion?
Purely selling, baby.
And those who get that promotion
sell better than you do.
That's the way it is.
They don't sell a car.
Their job could be human
resources or something,
but they learn how to sell themselves
as that position more than you.
Maybe you ought to learn how to do it.
It'll benefit you, make
you a lot of money.
Picasso once said, "Good artists copy,
"great artists steal."
This is one of Steve
Jobs's favorite quotes.
And Steve Jobs once said, "We
have always been shameless
"about stealing great ideas."
So wait a minute, is it
a good or a bad thing
to steal great ideas, and
being a great copycat?
'Cause I hear some people say sometimes,
"You know that guy copied my idea?
"That was my idea, I came up with this."
Listen, worry when nobody's
copying what you're doing,
because no one's paying attention to you.
It is a very, very, very big compliment
when somebody copies you.
Ask the question when you're thinking big,
why not you?
And answer it.
I'm not just doing this
motivational video.
Why not you?
Why shouldn't you win?
No, no, no, forget
motivational, let's get logical.
Why not you?
Actually answer that.
Why can't you be somebody
that can do something in your business
that's never been done before?
Why not you?
Answer it.
So give the argument.
Logically, here's why not me.
Because I don't work hard enough.
You can fix that.
Stop being lazy.
Well, whatever, but because
I'm not that good in sales.
You can learn sales.
So, okay, because I don't
know much about the product.
You can learn the product.
But why not you?
Because no one in my family's been rich.
So what?
No one was rich in Zuckerburg's family
before he became who he is today,
and nobody was in Jobs's.
Jobs's mom even gave him up for adoption.
So, whatever, but, so why not you?
Make the argument.
Why not you?
Truly get into it.
Then, give the other argument.
Why aren't you actually doing this?
Why shouldn't you be the person?
And say, I'm a very smart person.
I love people.
I actually like to make money,
to make a difference in the world.
And you know what?
I care for people, and I have
some things I want to do.
If I get money in my
pocket, it'll be good,
I'll do good with it.
And I got a big heart, and I am talented,
and da da da da da, and
I know the right people.
Boom, that's why not you.
Make both cases, as if you're an attorney
representing yourself.
One, why not you, meaning
you shouldn't be the person,
and the other, why not you,
meaning you should be the person.
Sell both of them, and then
see which argument wins.
Something tells me the argument
on this side's going to win.
But make that argument.
Take a sheet of paper
and make that argument.
Why not you?
Question that a little bit.
Who convinced you you can't do it?
Who convinced you you can't
be part of a group of people?
I watch so many guys on YouTube that,
you know, are, even some of these
guys are considered experts
by big magazines and have written
New York Times bestsellers,
and they say some shit
like, "Oh, you know,
"entrepreneurs are born."
Give me a damn break!
Entrepreneurship can be taught.
Entrepreneurship is an inspiration
that comes from here from some people
that want to solve a bigger problem.
What do you mean entrepreneurship
is something you're born with?
I completely disagree with that statement.
Fully disagree with that statement.
Jumping 48 inches?
That's God-given ability.
You can't do that.
Entrepreneurship, it is a formula.
If you hang around other
people that think like this,
and you watch this video,
and you watch all of Valuetainment
or some other people that are feeding
the right type of content to you,
and the right books you read,
your imagination won't stop working,
because the entrepreneur is numbers,
solving problems, how can
I do it better, faster.
Why can't you learn the skillsets?
Why can't you?
You can, so why not you?
And don't let anybody convince you
that people who solve some big problems
and are big thinkers have to be born
being big thinkers.
I'm here to tell you
you can figure out the
formula to thinking bigger.
Don't let them convince you
that these elite people.
Sometimes I sit around my friends,
who are worth money as well.
I'm around these guys all the time,
so now, you know, "Hey, Pat,
"come run the meeting,
"we're going to go have some
party with these billionaires,
"are we're going to go hang out?
"Okay, great, I'm going
to go with these guys, eh.
"You know, I was always
special because for--"
Oh my gosh, stop it already.
When you almost lost everything
you did not think you were special.
None of us do, and then we,
you know, have our break and we win.
And you can do it as well.
Most people only pay
attention to the final product
of a successful entrepreneur.
They say things like,
"I can never be like them."
or "They got lucky."
What most don't see is
what they've overcome.
(engine growls)
All the struggles, the daily rejections,
the heartaches, the betrayals,
the rumors, the criticism,
the empty bank account
and all those lonely nights
while trying to make
their vision a reality.
You see, the only difference
between the one who quits
and the one who doesn't is
that they showed up every day.
They worked hard every day.
They hustled every day.
They learned from a
proven mentor every day.
They improved every day.
They did all this even though
they felt like quitting
every day.
And eventually, they
became who they are today.
(melancholy music)
Hey thank you so much for
watching this video, here.
I also want to give a shout
out to Evan Carmichael
who I really believe the world needs more
Evan Carmichaels who figure out ways
on a daily basis to
inspire millions of people
around the world to go
out there and not give up
and pursue their dreams
because I firmly believe
one hundred percent of
all of world's problems
are going to be solved by
entrepreneurs and anybody
who is inspiring and giving
birth to other entrepreneurs.
I'm supportive of that
person and that's exactly
what Evan Carmichael
does with this channel.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I made this video because Isaac Mercado
asked me to, so if there's
a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Patrick
say that really inspired you?
What was the most relevant, most important
message that you took
from watching this video?
Leave it down in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Rebecca Love.
Rebecca thank you so, so, so much
for picking up a copy of my book.
It really, really means a lot to me.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.
(whooshing)